[MUSIC PLAYING]
JINGYU SHI: Hi, everyone.
Welcome to Modern
Android Notifications.
My name is Jingyu.
I'm a developer advocate in
the Partner Developer Team.
PAUL MATTHEWS: And
I'm Paul Matthews.
I'm a partner developer
advocate in London.
So three years
ago on this stage,
Chris Wren, an Android
engineer on the system UI,
gave this quote, and
it's a brilliant one.
"Don't annoy the user.
Respect them.
Empower them.
Delight them.
Connect them to the
people they care about."
And this is still
very much true today.
So we will look at channels
and how you can use them
in your app, what's new in
notifications, and finally,
Digital Wellbeing, but first,
how to respect your users.
So respect your
users' attention.
Don't annoy the user.
Respect them.
Some useful tips-- so do
respect the user's settings.
So if they've communicated
to you in your app
that they want a certain
setting for your notifications,
then you should respect that.
Don't try and override it.
Don't try and ignore it.
You should check that the
notifications you're sending
are not blocked, that
they do still want
to hear these notifications.
And finally, if you are
capable in your app,
you should backup any
settings that they've
told you about notifications.
And you should make
sure they're synced
over installs and over devices.
You should use
well-structured notifications
in your app, so making use of
the styles that we provide,
such as MessagingStyle,
InboxStyle, BigPictureStyle.
And you should make sure
that your notifications
are relevant and timely.
Great example is using
high priority FCM messages
to ensure that the user gets
the notification when you intend
them to get your notification.
And prioritize posting the
notifications first, and then
making them look even
better, so downloading
assets and that kind of thing.
Some don'ts, some basic don'ts--
don't just send
these notifications
and kind of forget about them.
So we really want you to use
the platform features that
are there to help you.
For instance, auto
cancel, making sure
that your notifications
disappear when they should.
Time outs, is a
notification really
relevant after four hours?
And synchronizing
across the devices--
if you know that your user uses
your app on multiple devices,
like tablets and desktops,
you should try and synchronize
notifications that
they dismiss on one
or read on one across others.
Don't send notifications
that are not actionable.
The point of notifications is
that they're there to be used.
By definition, the
user wants to know
something, which means they
generally need to do something.
So don't send them
a notification
that just tells
them hey, we sync
some stuff in the background.
This is not the best
use of notifications.
And finally, don't
annoy the user.
So when you post a
notification to them,
you should use alert
once, and make sure
that they're not getting
buzzed like crazy,
as they're standing up on stage
presenting about notifications.
And you should make sure
that the group notification
behavior is representative
of what you want.
So if you're a chat app, maybe
children group notification
behavior, or summary if
you're something else.
So respect the user.
Otherwise, they might just
turn off your notifications.
And then you've got no way
of communicating to them.
They might choose to
uninstall your app, which
would be far worse.
There are some platform features
that deliberately enable
notifications being turned off.
For instance, you can see here
the notifications being posted.
And the users maybe
keep swiping it away.
And so now in P,
we prompt the user.
Do you really care
about this notification?
Do you really want
to see this content?
This acts on channels.
So if you're not describing
your channels correctly,
then this can lead
to some confusion,
and perhaps some
lost notifications
from the user's perspective.
So let's talk more about
notification channels.
They provide granular
control to your notifications
for the user.
So you should empower the user.
And clearly, channels are
the way to empower them.
So let's look at
how to use them.
Well first of all, they're
now required on all apps.
They're required on API 26.
And that should be
everywhere prevalent now.
They help the user categorize--
they help you categorize
your notifications that help
the user to interact with them.
But more on that soon.
And finally, they allow the user
to customize their settings.
So the user has the final say.
So if you think
something is important
and they don't think it
is, they can tell you this.
So let's look at
the best practices.
Again, you should
allow the users
to manage their notifications
through the channel creation.
You should allow them to
maybe deep link into settings
to change these things.
If they are
expressing an interest
of working with your
notification channels,
perhaps they want
to be able to change
the importance of something.
So setting the right importance
level for a notification
channel seems like
an obvious one,
but it's so easy to overlook.
And finally, user settings--
you should respect the user
settings, as we said earlier.
But back them up where you can,
and don't try and abuse them
by deleting and recreating.
Other don'ts are only
using one channel.
This is a clear notification
smell, if you like.
If you've only got one
channel in your application,
there's probably something
else you need to be looking at.
If you provide poor
descriptions for users
so that they don't
really understand
what the purpose
of a channel is,
then they're not going to
be able to make the best
decisions.
Or if you use wrong
or blocked channels,
then this is probably,
you know, they're
trying to communicate
to you that they
don't like this content.
And you should respect that.
And finally, spamming the user
with notification channels
is just not the
best way to proceed.
So choosing your
channels can really
help, choosing your
channels carefully.
You really should
think of the user
when you create your channels,
not your application, not
your architecture.
Think of the user
and how they might
want to interact with your app.
For instance, it's a bad
idea to try and create
notification channels
around your importance level
that you find important.
So hey, this is a really
high priority thing.
This isn't what notification
channels are for.
You should group them
around categories
of notifications, for
instance, tagging in a photo,
or liked posts.
Let the user
communicate back to you
how they see that
type of notification.
You should also think about
creating notifications when
there is more control needed.
For instance, if
I'm on a chat app.
And I've got a general channel
for all chat notifications
coming in.
But then I express an
interest in controlling,
like, a family chat
group, you should create
a channel at that point, and
allow the user to dive deeper
and have more finely
grained control.
And finally, lazily
creating, so this comes back
to not creating too
many channels or groups.
And that is if Jingyu never
receives a direct message
through your app,
maybe you don't need
to create the channel for that.
And then the user can
provide feedback to you
to say, look, this is
useful or this isn't useful.
And you should listen to that.
So in Android P,
we added broadcasts
for listening in to
blocking or changing state
of your notification channels.
You should understand those.
And you should react to them.
You should maybe back them
up, so that the next time you
create a channel on a different
device, it makes sense.
And finally, you can query
these APIs at runtime
also to find out how the user
interacts with your channels.
So now, look at what's
new in notifications.
JINGYU SHI: Thank you, Paul.
Let's now look at what else
is new in notifications
on Android 9.
First, we added
some visual updates
to make the notifications
easier to read and scan through.
As you probably noticed,
we added more padding
single notification.
And we went back to
using the rounded corners
at the top and bottom.
The other improvement
that we really love
is this smooth app
opening animation
that you're seeing
here on the slide.
Instead of closing
the notification
and opening the app,
now the notification
transforms smoothly into
the app, which speeds up
the transition more than twice.
And you might ask, what do
you need to do to have this?
All you need to
do is to make sure
that you are starting
your activity directly,
and your activity
starts quickly.
Since for most users,
the notifications
they care about the most
are the ones connecting them
with the people they care.
So we enhanced our
MessagingStyle, our messaging
experience, by
adding a new person
class once you use API 28.
And if you're using
MessagingStyle in notification,
you can see that we have now
moved the people's avatar
to the left of the notification.
And you can set that avatar
by using the setIcon method.
We also added support
for images and stickers
in the messaging notification.
By using site data,
you can add image
in your messaging
notification directly.
The other feature that I love
on Android is direct reply.
But sometimes when I'm
replying to a notification,
I would accidentally
tap on the notification,
and that will open the app.
And my response is lost.
But on Android 9 you can
help the user with this.
By retrieving the
draft from this extra,
you can populate the
response in your app.
So make the user experience
better, delight them.
If you already support
Smart Reply in your app,
we highly recommend that
you use the setChoices API
to also display them
in your notification.
Instead of replying
to the notification,
user can now just tap
one of them to reply.
OK, here's an example
we have for creating
MessagingStyle notification
using the new APIs.
So first, we're going to create
an instance, a person instance,
here.
So we're going to use
the person builder.
As you can see, we are
setting the names, the URI,
the icon for this person.
And this is going to represent
the sender in a message.
And then we're going to
pass that to this message
that we're creating here.
As you can see, we're passing
the instance of the person,
not like before,
where we were passing
the name of that person.
And in this message, we also
want to include the image.
So we're using the setData
method to include that image.
And then after that,
we're adding this message
with another message.
So we're adding two messages
into this MessagingStyle
notification.
And then we're setting the
style into our notification.
OK, so here's a quick summary of
some of the dos and don'ts when
you're using MessagingStyle.
First, please use
MessagingStyle for messages.
And this also
applies for if you're
building for Android
Auto or Android Wear.
If you're sending
messaging notifications,
please use MessagingStyle.
In the past, we've
seen developers
switching between MessagingStyle
and some other styles,
like BigPictureStyle, in
order to create that big image
expansion presentation.
But now with setData method
you don't need to do that.
You can just use MessagingStyle.
And this will create a
consistent experience
for the user.
And it's always good to add
that icon for the people
in the notification.
So we highly recommend that you
use setIcon to add that avatar.
But if you don't
set the icon, we
will use the initial for
the name for that person
to create that
visual presentation.
And finally, if your app
supports Smart Reply,
please add that into
your notification,
so you are creating a better
experience for the user.
And here's a few things
that you want to avoid.
There are a lot of
good reasons to auto
cancel a notification, in order
to give the user a clean and up
to date notification jar.
But after user replies to
a notification, a messaging
notification, this is
not one of those cases.
You would want to keep
that notification there.
So if user want to return
to this conversation
and reply afterwards.
So please don't cancel that.
And let the users
swipe away when they're
finished with the conversation.
The other bad behavior
that we've seen in the past
is some developers are
setting this empty name,
in order to achieve a
visual presentation.
But on Android 9,
please don't do that.
There are two reasons.
One is because it will break on
Android 9, on the presentation.
And the other reason is
because a person without a name
is not a real person.
So up until now, we
will talk about how
you can reach the user--
how you can help your
user connect with people
they care about, and how you can
make your notification a better
experience for the user.
But I want to hit pause
here, and look at app usage
from the other side.
Since as much as I want
to get that notification
from my friend and
family, I still
need time away from the device.
So to help users with this, we
announced the Digital Wellbeing
at I/O this year.
If you have a [INAUDIBLE]
device running Android 9,
I highly recommend that you
download it from the Play
Store, and sign up for beta.
So this is what Digital
Wellbeing will show us.
It provides an overview
of our app usage
and provides dashboards
that shows our time spending
on each app, and the
number of notifications
that we've received.
I personally love using
Digital Wellbeing to learn
where I'm spending my time.
But sometimes I would
find that one or two apps
are sending me a lot of
notifications unexpectedly.
So one question
you might have is,
how are these
notifications counted?
Since this is still in beta,
the counting method may change.
But the goal is to track
user interruptions.
So in general, any newly
created notifications
are counted as one.
And any updates that's
visible to the user
are also counted
as one, which means
if you're sending a notification
to the block channel, that
is not counted here.
So in this case, I saw
this app is sending me
lots of notifications.
So I got curious.
I went into the dashboard.
And I opened that to see
the hourly breakdown.
And as you can see here, I
got notifications every hour
that day.
And even at 4:00
AM in the morning,
I got eight notifications.
So if these notifications
are high importance,
I would be woken up in
the middle of the night.
But thankfully,
that's not the case.
But if these notifications
are push notifications,
and they are sent using high
priority FCM message, which
means this app is constantly
waking up a deep dose device.
If I want to have good
battery in the morning,
I might just uninstall this app.
But for now, I will turn
on DND, Do Not Disturb,
so that I don't get disturbed.
Digital Wellbeing also
provides ways for users
to disconnect and
reduce interruption.
And on Pixel 3, you
can even turn on DND
by simply flip your device,
which is super convenient.
But what if this is a super
important notification
that the user actually
wants to receive?
So for those, here's
a few advice for you.
First, set the right category
to your notification.
As we can see here in the
do not disturb setting,
user can choose what to
block and what to allow.
And they can set exceptions
on calls, messages, reminders,
and events.
If your notification
belongs to one of them,
please tag your
notification as such.
Here are listed a
few categories which
correspond to these
exceptions on the other side.
As I said, if your
notification belongs
to one of these
categories, please let us
know by tagging them.
The other advice that
we have is if this
is a notification coming
from another person, then
please tag your notification.
As you can see here in the
do not disturb setting,
user can choose who they
want to get a notify from,
from their contacts.
So please add that person
in your notification,
and add the associated
URI, if possible.
Doing this will allow you
to bypass do not disturb.
But you should always remember
that when user turn on
do not disturb, they really
don't want to be disturbed.
So if you're sending
a notification that's
not expected, that
will really annoy them.
So please don't abuse these
APIs, which this brings us
back to the quote we
had at the beginning,
where we're saying whenever
you're sending a notification,
please keep this in mind.
Don't annoy the user,
respect them, empower them,
delight them, and connect them
to the people they care about.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]